Le Festivoix de Trois-Rivières
est le premier grand événement
à sauter dans l'arène.
THOMAS GRÉGOIRE, D.g. et
artistique du Festivoix
- Beaucoup de fébrilité
parce que ça fait un petit
moment que l'on a pas monté
notre festival.
Un événement qui propose
habituellement des spectacles
sur 16 scènes pour environ 300
mille visiteurs sera réduit à
trois scènes avec un maximum
de 10 mille festivaliers.
Dans notre cas à nous on
ne pourra pas se rendre à plus
de 1500 personnes sur l'ensemble
du site à cause de l'aménagement
que l'on a choisi.
Fini les passeports donnant
accès au lieu librement.
Espace pour délimiter
les sièges, horaire de spectacle
décalé, tout pour respecter
les règles de la Santé publique.
Et c'est encore beaucoup
d'ajustements de dernières
minutes parce que les couleurs
des zones changent.
Même que la Santé publique
a annoncé cette semaine que
les événements pouvaient
recevoir 3500 personnes soit
mille de plus qu'il y a quelques
jours à peine
On va avoir ici notre salon RH
chevaline.
La plus grande exposition
agricole, celle de Ste-Hyacinthe
reçoit habituellement 200 milles
visiteurs.
DAVID MESSIER, directeur Expo.
agricole de Sainte-Hyacinthe
- Avec les mesures sanitaires en
place, bien on peut aller
jusqu'à 7 500 par jour parce
qu'on a divisé dans le fond
en trois plages horaire avec
un maximum de 2500 par jour
donc ça tourne autour
de 30 mille personnes.
Ici aussi on a choisi de ne pas
augmenter la capacité pour
le moment faute de main
d'oeuvre.
Étalées sur quatre jours
au lieu de dix les activités
seront-elles rentables?
- Si la vente d'accès se passe
bien oui on va avoir un
événement serré évidemment
chaque sous va être compté,
mais si on fait bien nos devoirs
on va être correct.
FRANÇOIS G. CHEVRIER, Directeur
général, Événement Attraction
- Ils vont être rares
les promoteurs qui vont réussir
à faire de l'argent cette année.
- C'est pourquoi le Ministère
québécois du Tourisme a bonifié
ses programmes d'aide de 15
millions de dollars sur 2 ans.
- Et le fédéral a réservé
une enveloppe de 400 millions
pour les festivals et
événements.
- Ça vient combler une partie
de la réalité, mais les revenus
autonomes qui se calculent
en billetterie, en concessions
alimentaires en produits
dérivés, ça, ça va manquer.
- Ce qui ne devrait pas manquer,
ce sont les festivaliers.
- Bien oui, c'est sûr qu'on va
aller au festival, on attend
ça depuis longtemps.
Avez-vous hâte?
oui beaucoup ça m'a manqué
l'année passée.
Pour que le coeur du Québec
batte à nouveau.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Mont